joining me now is lara logan the host of
logan has no agenda on fox nation lyra
thanks for joining me tonight um it does
sound like a little bit of a hey that's
a nice country you have there from pac
you know pakistan telling us a nice
little country you have there if you
don't uh you know be really bad if
something happened to it like they're
saying you better release this nine
million dollars of frozen assets in the
federal uh reserve or else you know
we're going to get terrorism again so
sound a little bit like blackmail uh-huh
is this another hostage situation well
the pakistanis have been blackmailing
the us right for decades with their
nuclear capability right and congressmen
and senators on both sides they are are
stupid enough to believe that the only
policy of is one of appeasement that's
the only one that can work never mind
that india is a nuclear power right
there and they're not threatening uh to
flood the u.s with terrorists right and
you know this is much worse than anybody
realizes i've had um you know the last
few hours have been incredibly
significant for me because
i've had people stepping forward to
speak up because they're so horrified by
what they're seeing right now what the
united states government is doing people
stepping forward from where well this is
afghan and american sources with direct
knowledge of what is happening who are
directly involved what happened when the
when the taliban offensive was going on
afghan pilots fled to uzbekistan that
was one of the places they went the
afghan pilots were part of the afghan
air force and they have been in
uzbekistan and the united states
government as i understand it from these
people who are directly involved
multiple sources including even guards
on the ground in uzbekistan say that the
u.s has agreed to give all of that uh
air force capability to the taliban okay
so we're talking about seven uh black
hawk helicopters we're talking about
close air support um what you've got
there is four mission capable 829
fixed-wing aircraft spor for special
special mission wing mi-17s two little
birds and so on these are aircraft that
have some of them at least two of them
have very very very sensitive
intelligence gathering capability on it
and when i say sensitive i mean i'm
talking about cameras that do day and
night missions that also allow for laser
targeting of people on the ground this
is what our military is equipped with
and the united states is allowing this
false narrative to be perpetuated and
the media is dutifully carrying this
narrative that somehow we have to do
this we have no choice because we've got
to get those american citizens out you
know and what people are raising to me
intelligence people veterans active duty
military people um not just military
people by the way intelligence personnel
um they're saying it seems to them
almost as if the u.s was quite happy to
let these american citizens fall into
the taliban so that they can then be
used as the justification for what
they're doing because
there are standard operating procedures
that every single person in the military
and intelligence agencies know have to
be followed so when you withdraw you
don't leave that capability behind and
also if you leave it behind you have the
option of activating all of your systems
that are designed to destroy that
destroy it exactly like everybody else
stealth uavs and so on so now we have
you know first-hand reports that
indicate that not only is the u.s
sending uh money to the taliban not only
are they letting them keep this
equipment and capability that they have
but that they're actually going to take
very sensitive significant capability
from uzbekistan where it is not in the
hands of the taliban and they've agreed
to give it to them and when it comes to
the humanitarian aid can i just say i've
been reporting for you know about a week
now that they were going to pass off the
money to the taliban as humanitarian aid
this was planned it was part of the
talks zorma kalazad knows all about this
so does tony blinken and susan rice and
jake sullivan and millie mckenzie all of
them they have blood on their hands and
right now there is an urgent crisis
going on in the pancha valley where the
afghans are still fighting and the u.s
is watching this happen and they're
allowing pakistan to carry out mass
killings from house to house to house
beheading two twelve-year-old boys
killing women and children killing the
president of afghanistan's brother today
in the panchayat valley it's just
unbelievable we should actually be
helping the resistance fighters but i
have to tell you larry after seeing that
the biden administration wouldn't even
give the internet to the freedom
fighters in cuba um it doesn't surprise
me that they're not lifting a finger
here as well great information that's
breaking news for all of you thank you
for sharing that with us tonight thank
you